hi my name is Jenny Turner tri-ring and
today I'm going to be talking about
how's my okay sounds weird to me today
I'm going to be talking about working
with maps extracting features for
traffic crashing sites I have a
volunteer with insight Lane which is an
open source volunteer civic good project
through data for democracy we build
tools to help cities and advocacy groups
better understand traffic crash risk we
do this by using a machine learning
model to predict traffic rush stress
given road teachers then we visualize
the traffic crashing risk and we can run
this on any city that has traffic crash
data with geographic coordinates such
latitude longitude this talk that we'll
focus is on how you can work up maps but
we'll be using insight lanes feature
engineering pipeline as an example
briefly I'm listing the libraries I'm
using on the topic for future reference
I'm not going to go through them now but
you can go back and look at this
afterwards this is a Dewberry notebook
for the slides and I'm making it
available on my github include some code
snippets that I'm talking about and also
some more complex and that's after the
fact that you can go back and look at
and the full algorithms for all of this
are available on an insulating project
github which all we do at the end as
well
so say you want to work with maps you
might have one map just for one sitting
you may have other geographical data but
no map for insightly we used cities open
data crash information which have often
either just a CSV a lot of tooth
longitude but they don't have any map
associated with it you might want to
combine Geographic data from several
data sources so the crash data and then
something else and you might even want
to combine multiple maps together to get
features for insightly we want any city
to be able to use our tools and so we're
using maps from Open Street Map as our
base map and then we can add other
geographic features onto the map Open
Street Map is a free open crowd source
map of the world it's very widely used a
lot of third-party services use it for a
variety of things such as a base map for
visualization routing applications and
math features here's a screenshot of
central square in Cambridge
Massachusetts you can see it her eyes
the roads both the more major roads in
yellow and the the more minor roads in
white there's a bunch of different
features as well traffic signals there's
a surveillance camera crosswalks cafes
and banks and other things and so it's
really well populated with a lot of
information about original OpenStreetMap
ever since their data has elements this
consists of nodes which are geographical
points so anything with a lot of two
longitude this consists of things like
the traffic signals and cafes some of
the things like that and then there are
ways which are ordered lists of notes
and this is how they represent in snow
streets so it sort of represents the the
curvature of the road we're also here
for some things like parks you have a
polygon you start and you ended the same
note but you tricks the line around and
then they have relationships between
elements so administrative boundaries
around the cities you can have turning
restrictions for one street to another
street and they also provide future
information for their elements using
tags and I'll come back to tags in a
moment so if you've decided you want to
use over the street map and you want to
get data out you can use the overpass
API which is a read on the API for
accessing Open Street Map data and there
are a variety packages you can search
for that use over best this is great if
you want to get like most of the
information for our region but we're
going to be talking about OS 7x instead
which is a Python package that allows
users to easily download OpenStreetMap
road network data so it throws out a lot
of stuff like the cafe information which
you may or may not care about but for us
we just care about the road network it's
either used for downloading the street
networks you can write the resulting
road networks out easily
and I alluded to this tutorial here
again my slides will be made available
so if you want to use open a street map
oh it's have annexed to get the cities
road network from the street map it's
pretty straightforward you just import
it and you can do something like grass
replaced with Cambridge and then you can
pop they're rapin so this is the road
network for Cambridge and it's pretty
easy to do but not all the cities on the
street map have their administrative
boundaries defined Cambridge does but if
your city that you want to get a street
network full data for doesn't then there
are other ways you can use those and
then I skip the data you can get data
within a certain radius or if you have a
polygon for the region you care about
you can get that over the street map so
I 7x and so we can make it and look at
Central Square in Cambridge and you can
just graph from the point so you've got
the Central Square and the distance of
175 metres and you can graph the road
network here the previous the graphic
questions I've talked about so far the
default is to simplify the road network
but you might want to actually look at
the unsimplified network what does this
mean it still removes all the nodes that
are part of the road network so cafes
and other things that are not directly
related to driving or walking or biking
around but at least you can see it
leaves a lot more nodes in the road an
hour and this correspond and some of
these nodes correspond to the curvature
of the road or to crosswalks or traffic
signals that might fall outside of the
middle of the intersection so depending
on what you're doing you might want the
simplified version and playing over to
anyway I want a more complex version and
pass of the e simplify false
so I mentioned tags before this is how
the street Matthew describes features of
elements there are key value pairs
anyone can have a tag there's a way you
might have a tag
in a name which either road name whether
or not the road is one way it's a cycle
track and that's the cycle facility and
that's a laying or a track and then
notes can have tabs as well the highway
tag can correspond to select traffic
signals stop signs and crossings just
don't we care a lot about and you can
have an amenity tag that corresponds to
a post box or a cafe oh this is by no
means an exhaustive list of tags so
let's look at some of the notes with bio
a tag because this is a feature that we
might care about it inside lane traffic
signals and stop signs might be in
dative of greater or less risk in our
road network traffic recipe so OS 7x
returns a multi diagraph and we can
convert it into a panda's data frame and
then we can look at any tag and you note
it has a highway tag with either traffic
signals the OSM signals their or stop
and we'll see that there are 260 traffic
signals in the OpenStreetMap data for
cambridge and there's seven stop signs
really there's one of the seven stop
signs in Cambridge Road networks an open
stream are generally quite good so many
organizations use it for routing they
need to be good you can't use them
relatively otherwise but some of the
other features on there are only good as
the crowd sourcing and that only gives
people actually want to use it so if
nobody's ever said hey I really care
about the stop signs in Cambridge maybe
no one ever put them in so that turns
out to be a feature we can't use in our
model who must really get the data
somewhere else can we use this suit
signals if the stop signs are neither
can we rely on the signals we can figure
this out we can compare it against the
open data from the city of Cambridge as
municipal government I feel like Kelly's
keynote was a really good introduction
here about all the cool things you can
do with open data and Cambridge has
known for a lot of cities out
programs and so you can go and you can
check out all the neat things like
squirrel counts off of open data portals
squirrel counts are probably not useful
for Road risk so if we're gonna compare
the signals the OpenStreetMap signals to
the municipal open data signals I
downloaded this shapefile from the city
of Cambridge is open data portal and
then I just used johannah's to read in
the shapefile pretty easy to do and I
see that there are 175 traffic signals
and municipal aid provided compared to
the 260 traffic signals in OpenStreetMap
so that's not as far as the stop signs
but it's still a little bit off and I
think we'd like to look at this a little
bit further before we use it as a
feature in our model but I have to step
back first so we have the oldest tree of
network data and we have ways which
broadly correspond to roads and nodes
which broadly correspond to
intersections and depending on what
you're doing this might be enough
intersections are I do have a higher
pressures
but for insightly it isn't quite enough
first of all the OpenStreetMap nodes
don't provide a lot of features compared
to the waves they might say that there's
a traffic signal there but it won't talk
about the width or the one-wayness of
the road coming into the intersection
and also crashes might not happen
exactly at the point where the two roads
cross and it doesn't handle complex
intersections either if you have two
intersections right next to each other
with two different nodes then maybe you
want to treat that as one system that
drivers are having thrown away that
people are passing through so we're
going to use a different abstraction
this notion of segments which expands
the concept of intersection and we're
basing it off an algorithm by as abeja
which I link to you get my slides so
first we need to do a little
pre-processing we saw earlier that you
can turn no 7 X output into a Gio
panda's data frame you can also write
the o7x output to file you can use the
function save graph shape file and that
positive I don't have but this year but
in hidden slide from the Jupiter nut
and even doing that and it'll be post
processed into a JSON format because
that's how unsightly internally handles
our Maps once we post processes we can
read the geo JSON map in and then roads
are open street map waves and
intersection points are the remaining
nodes after we do the OS eminent
simplification and after we drop dead
ends but we want to treat intersections
a sort of a bigger space than just that
at that point so what we do is we create
a 20 meter buffer around each
intersection just draw that circle
we shape these buffer library for this
then some of these are more complex and
so we merge these together and any
overlapping buffer we were choosing
shape the shared libraries uni reunion
function and take all the road segments
inside those bubbles and they were the
intersection segments and so you can see
the sort of straightforward
intersections there and more complex
intersection here and then the resulting
non intersection segments sir's to all
the road segments that are left over
after which Scooby the intersections
from the previous slide alright so we've
defined this road segment when you're
working with multiple geographic data
sets you need a framework against which
to compare the data sets and so ours is
this road segment abstraction once
you've done that you need to make sure
the data sets have the same coordinate
reference system I'll talk about that in
a moment and then you want to visualize
your data probably I can be a good idea
to make sure nothing weird is going on
with it you can have it'll help you
debug and I recommend if you're just
trying to understand what's going on and
this is an option where you work with a
city or a region that you are familiar
with Cambridge is my example because I
live there
and so I can get a good sense of whether
things are behaving as they should be so
our example is comparing the traffic
signals from the city of Cambridge as
municipal data against the OpenStreetMap
data so first you need to make sure that
they are they have the same projection
when we're working with maps they're
flat the earth is terrible ish and so
you need to project all the things on
the surface of the earth on a flat
surface and when you do that you're
going to be introducing some sort of
distortion you can see the picture of my
daughter and she sends the distortion
into that Ghost on the pumpkin and since
you're introducing distortion you need
to have it be consistent to start so
they're introducing and so that's why
you need the same projection for
everything you're working with a lot of
data you'll see when you're looking at
open data will begin epsg 43:26 which
corresponds to sort of what we think of
as latitude and longitude and typically
see data stored in 43:26 but maybe
display ever worked within 38:57
so you just always need to check your
datasets coordinate reference system and
this is a really great reference below
to learn more about projections doesn't
actually a very complex topic so we need
to reconnect our data I'm going to give
two examples of how to reconnect data on
the Cambridge admissible data set the
first is going to be using geo pandas
it's pretty straightforward really you
just you can use the two CRS function to
give it the projection that you want and
then you just have to make sure that
you're updating the data frames
co-coordinator for the system to be
whatever it is you're converting into XI
okay this is very straightforward to use
but I found that it can be pretty slow
in larger data sets and so for insightly
we use my brush fiber odds you need to
know of the initial projection is so
we'll check out this misty our essence
22:49
which is not forward 326 it's the
Massachusetts mainland production so
always check and then pipe Raj has a
transformer object that you can give the
initial the starting and the ending
projection and use that to transform the
coordinates it's a little more complex
when you're looking at lines
and polygons and it is with points which
is why you're just playing around
smaller day access to your pandas might
be a better option and then I wanted to
make sure this was working so I just
check to see that the data frame for the
Geo pandas protection was the same as
the data frame from the PI project
rejection and they are so that's good
alright so we have behind the scenes I
did the OpenStreetMap data as well I
open it to file behind the scenes and
then I used the qqe to visualize most of
the time and so the picture there is
just a portion of these signaled and the
second data for Ingrid in the key is
doing the outline later lines are the
evidence street map traffic signals and
the dark circle is the municipal signal
so we'll see often the features of one
dataset might be close to but not
identical to the other dataset these are
no don't let them exactly but they do
correspond to the same intersection so
what we want to do is standardize the
new data sets and in our case that
involves finding the closest road
segments are intersections and non
intersection segments from before and
figuring out what the closest one
segment is to the all the signals and
you can do this by iterating through all
your segments all your points
that's very slow so I recommend using
the archery library for our indexing
special things and that seems it up a
lot the code for all of this mapping
points to segments is so that you can
read a book you can go back and look at
that later and it instantly uses this
technique of mapping points to Road
segments to standardize any point based
feature that we want to add to our model
all right so five nurses in my sugar nut
but they're not gonna see it at the
moment so we're just calling five
nearest on both our municipal data and
urban street map data and then we'll see
that we've got this near ID which is the
segment ID associate this particular
point great so how does this work well
most of the signals it turns out are
pretty well aligned and matched for the
same segment and sometimes you'll see
the OpenStreetMap has several segments
on an intersection there's only one
municipal signal and that seems to be
because of the street map maybe
recording every place there's a label
with the traffic light on it and
Cambridge is only doing it for the
intersection as all but there are so
some segments that match only with the
signal and one is that not the other one
so we can find the signals you need to
each data set by looking at the ones
that Cambridge has a segment ID but it's
there's no segment ID for OpenStreetMap
and vice-versa and we'll see that there
are 17 signals that are in the municipal
cambridge data that don't appear on the
OpenStreetMap data and in 41 extra
signals in the OpenStreetMap data that
don't appear in the cambridge data the
municipal there so let's dig into this
even a little further will help put the
mismatching it extends to file pool
visualize them again and this time I
wanted to know what's going on and I
happen to look at just the intersection
segment and not the combined segments
and discovered that all of those open
street maps like traffic signals fall
outside of the intersection and so that
is why we're seeing more signals for
Cambridge and one set of segments and
more signals for Open Street Map
somewhere else so this may mean that our
abstraction is new agree I looked at the
Google Street View version of this
intersection and found its really big
intersection with very wide lanes so
you're a phony meter buffer isn't big
enough maybe we want to expand our
intersection segment concept for complex
intersections
or maybe we want to say that signals
really should follow intersections and
instead of mapping them to the nearest
segment whether it's an intersection or
a non intersection segment we want to
map it to just the intersections and
that's so that's something that I'm not
going to talk about now to think about
for later but this is still accounts for
many of the mismatches we see in our
data sets there's some remaining ones I
was looking at if the remaining ones
weren't OpenStreetMap but not the
municipal data I could visualize them in
OpenStreetMap directly so you can search
for nodes or ways and you'll see that
this is a blinking traffic light not a
standard yellow red green one and so
here just is not including that so that
explains that I mean we should filter
out the blinking signals from our data
set but I think on the whole we've been
using the OpenStreetMap data actually
not analyzed at this carefully before
when we use it as a feature I think it's
probably decent for what we're using it
for although I shouldn't think about the
size of the intersections and so that's
just one way you can look at combining
two different data sets and trying to
understand what's going on so what have
we learned
first of all of history that might not
match the Missal data may be way off
let's stop signs that might be a little
off you might be interested in updating
OpenStreetMap for your city of interest
this is definitely something you can go
and do if you find such as important to
you you could go ahead and add them you
might be able to find the stop sign data
set for your city and and add it
automatically or maybe you ought to be
more sense to get it and figure out what
everything is I wouldn't recommend that
it's also a good idea to check your data
to see if it makes sense and in our
project as in any projects there's a lot
of data limitations so the geographical
data limitations you might see are that
ministry map is internally consistent
across cities for the most part but it
may be incomplete municipal data can
also be inconsistent either within a
city or between cities so the
projections can differ
Mastan you represent a different
and also cities collect data and that
can be an all sorts of crazy different
formats the City of Boston present
collects automatic traffic recordings
and they put it in a spreadsheet and the
spreadsheet there's like three different
spreadsheet formats and they sort of
count by hour then depends on what
stretch you're looking at whether it
matches up and so you have to write this
like very complex custom code to be able
to process stuff like that so you might
choose this maybe that's not worth to
adding it or maybe it's worth your time
to pre-process the data but for months
can be quite a bit different all right
so insight Lane uses these in any point
based feature we can add to our model by
using the same technique we looked at
before so this can be the OpenStreetMap
data you can get data from municipal
data parking tickets might be
interesting to look at maybe street
trees maybe squirrels who knows and some
cities also make their look publicly
crowd-sourced data like three one one
data publicly available maybe you'd like
to look at that figure about it and you
can also add features from other maps to
the Open Street Map or just combine
together Maps when we started this
project we use it was just out of Boston
and Boston gave us a municipal this map
set for this and it had a bunch of
features on the segment's like speed
limit which was well populated
OpenStreetMap speed living as spawning
with annual average daily traffic and
the type of road and a bunch of other
useful features when we extended this
project to include any city and used the
Open Street Map data we didn't want to
lose these features so how could we
combine the maps that says might give us
with the administrative maps that were
generally using well it's tricky maps
don't always line up perfectly this is a
picture of Open Street Map and and the
Boston is Oh map together the light blue
one in the middle is Boston's municipal
map and the two ones around it are the
street
the Google screenshot shows that
OpenStreetMap is treating this is two
one-way roads because of that median in
the middle and Boston is treating this
as one to a road but really it's the
same road and we'd like to be able to
use the features for the Boston map so
how can we combine this so we're gonna
have to treat intersections and not
intersections that means differently
first thing we'll do is look at
intersections I have this little fake
one of my street here instances just
useful for the example first we create a
buffer around the OpenStreetMap
intersection segment then you create
buffers around all of the municipal
intersection segments we just look at
the buffers and overlap again we'll use
our tree to find the ones that are
nearby and so we have two overlapping
segments here and the one in the middle
the one associated with Boston the
intersection is overlaps the
OpenStreetMap
buffer entirely and the think one way
intersection doesn't so we choose that
as the match for non intersection
segments it's similar but you see some
some differences you might have sort of
two short segments the two lines that
both correspond to the black line and
you also might have other parallel lines
that are nearby so what we do is we look
for we do a buffer again around the
saying we're trying to match so the
black line here and if we do a small
buffer we'll see that these two lines
are within it and we'll just take those
lines as the matches but if those lines
weren't there we would then expand the
buffer and a larger buffer around this
black line would capture the further on
line we would use that as the match and
we get about low to mid-90s on the
segments between Boston and the
OpenStreetMap
segments so it's pretty good for adding
features
all right so now you blow the process
map data okay the source code again but
for this presentation will be linked at
the end of the topic I encourage you to
go and play around if you're interested
in understanding this a little more
deeply and then what do we enough talk
about first is to not forget to think
about equity and second I want to show
you inside things crash model because
we're very proud of it
all right so what's a common data
science pitfall is doing analysis on
data that some that inadvertently
contributes to equity and just you
always have to think about how this
might happen and we can do it so Boston
for instance has a neighborhood slow
streets program and this is traffic
calming on a neighborhood low so if
you're not familiar with traffic calming
its engineering changes to the road so
that drivers would go more slowly but if
you traffic on one Street and everyone's
going slowly they might switch over the
next three over and that's frustrating
to a neighborhood so Boston wants to
treat neighborhoods on a holistic level
and slow the streets in general so
you're not seeing those impacts and so
neighborhoods in Boston you can apply to
participate in this and I'm not sure
about the details of the application
process but it includes letters of
support coming from community groups and
maybe some public meetings and things
like that once they have the
applications they evaluate them based on
objective criteria and this was a bunch
of things including high pressure areas
schools for children living in the
neighborhood a number of seniors in
proximity to transit so they are
objective criteria these things are
either true or false or cap others
numbers associated with them and some of
them I think are good features you
probably you want to reduce crashes in
area
how dangerous dresses already I
conceived an argument for wanting to do
scratches and make it safer around
places where kids welcome to school a
lot but proximity to transit is one
that's tricky because it might mean that
people are walking a lot more because
they're close to transit but
historically marginalized communities
have been have had less access to
transit so if you're using this as a
feature to make a decision based on who
gets low streets are you making
inadvertently biasing it towards a
decision that means that marginalized
communities get slow shoots less and so
bus I think is aware of this and they
and they have been tweaking their model
but this is just something to think
about whenever you're doing these
assignments where you're making the
students how did this didn't have people
in ways that we might not want its
impact in here is the unsightly crash
model we feed features into a machine
learning model and Catholics the crash
risk and we can display the results in
that form
the darker lines are higher risk and the
letter lines are lower risk and this is
the bike crash risk map because many
cities provide what what the mode the
first vehicle or pedestrian or bike type
they're using and so we actually filter
these out and you can also I'm not sure
I think it muddies the map for this
presentation you can click the show
crashes button it will display those
crashes for bikes in this case and we
also show the highest percentage as
predicted by our model for the city of
Cambridge that's it thank you you can
email me you can find my presentation on
my github presentations and if you're
interested in getting involved there's
two ways I even get involved you could
be interested in modeling your own
cities treacherous we don't currently do
New York we have about five cities that
we have on our website but or maybe it's
other city that you're from you really
want to visualize the crash dress so you
can do this you can also get involved
with us and volunteer and write some
code
and the liver products so it can be more
useful so you can check our website with
the visualization from the previous
slide insightly Network and our github
is there and you go and we'll talk you
through how to run our pipeline for your
new city or I can get involved with us
thank you um you said one part is making
sure that the data analytics analyst
doesn't contribute it and equity so how
do you check for that do you check as
their team has their me like certain
groups out there concern dog do you talk
to your stakeholders because we're not
aware of our blind spots so how do you
become more where your clients awesome
how does it keep you that that is a
really great question I don't have a
great answer for it I think that the
more people you can talk to you the
better the more broadly you can make
your product avail the different
stakeholders the more life in New York
and maybe that it's a little raise an
issue I think there's also some great
books to read about inequity of Kathy
O'Neill's weapons of mass destruction I
think that was one of them I enjoyed it
and thought it was useful and like we've
also found out a longer answer there's
there's a thing that some cities have
fall divisions the oil which will allow
people to go and enter their concerns
around intersections or other areas and
saying this is dangerous because people
speed or there's not enough time to
process erode and we can use that as a
feature and that we do I think at this
point we're still doing a lot of explore
analysis and no one is actually making
decisions based on our product yet but
when I would talk to Philadelphia there
they do some people in Philadelphia do
use our product to visualize things they
didn't want to use the vision zero data
and I think that's that's a reasonable
decision to make because who is entering
the data who has the time and the smart
phones or whatever to like actually
spend the time saying I at this
intersection it's no good are we are we
collecting data in a fair way so I think
the more people you talk to and just
make sure that you're also talking
people sing to ride acres but it's a
hard question
this is my domain of expertise so I
can't speak about the other domains they
may be hugely problematic in ways I'm
not familiar with I think probably I
think that because we have such any
segregation historically and the built
environment changes based on like where
you are and that is contributed by
segregation I I think yes I think
Geographic data is it can be a really
hard thing to to make a boat alone so
extra good to be aware for that
[Music]
I think it's almost very conch I don't
know this is a question as much that is
the comment so please keys but I feel
like this idea of inequity is gonna be
coming up but it was mentioned in the
first you know and to me it seems like a
very obvious solution that looking
around in a room it still needs work is
why not just hire people from
marginalized communities like I grew up
without a car or we were that poor I can
tell you how much it sucks to go down
the street the next year like a six-lane
Street not even a highway right and so
if you want to talk with an equity I
mean it just makes it seems like such a
simple things are just like hey why
don't we get a bunch of you know poor
black and brown and vicious people in
our data science teams like I don't and
again I think that's more of a comment
can I just yes
I think that's a great great point and I
probably should have been a more
explosive I don't work for a company
this is fault I mean we should be doing
a lot of outreach ourselves but I think
that there's a lot be said for you know
examining hiring practices and seeing
what we can do and that direction and if
there's not an unconference on that do
you want to propose an unconference on
equity
experiment we talk I was just wondering
if you incorporated time series data at
all or if you were missing or
projections on your hands
when we started this project we were
looking at doing time series and we
looked at some weather things and some
time of year things and our datasets are
pretty small and so we just found that
that was not and the point we're at it
was hard to deal with and so we removed
the time dado but I think that's
actually a really good point you know
that the day after daylight savings time
with a new day that's a higher traffic
crash risk and so there's suddenly
things you can get from that hey thank
you um I was wondering you said that
before now this is mainly exploratory
work and I was here is to know what your
opinions we're on what possible
applications would be and how you see
this going fern
I guess I shouldn't have used the Rex
larger I think about a little farther
along that land and I sort of cope so we
are still looking we're working a little
bit with the city of Melbourne to
visualize freshness but we're still
looking for cities to get involved with
and also I think advocacy groups who
want to better understand their traffic
crashes and so maybe they can more
effectively lobby their cities I think
are a good user for this so we I think
the big limitation it was in mini data
science limitations is if you have this
black box machine learning model you're
saying this this road is really
high-risk and traffic departments don't
want to make a decision based on on our
say-so so one of the next thing we're
interested in looking at is is saying
like why our model says that it's high
risk and so then they can look at it and
they may be more willing to make
decisions based on that since we're
using Open Street Map is the base map I
think we're assuming that gets updated
as reasonable frequency and we do
occasionally pull it again but missile
apps can definitely get out of date and
we're looking at some of these features
and they don't map to something because
the room doesn't exist anymore I think
that is a real risk I think I want to
talk to me afterwards if anyone wants to
talk about open data or Maps I would
love to hear from you thank you
[Applause]